hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
did you know google can help with your
math homework here are five google math
tricks you must try
number one use google's built-in
calculator
if you go to google and type in the word
calculator
the result will be a scientific
calculator
you can use the keypad to do basic
arithmetic
for example 12 times 13 is equal to 156
but you can also use the keypad for more
complicated calculations like the sine
of pi over 2 radians is equal to 1.
but you're not just limited to this
keypad
you can also use natural language
searches
for example let's say you wanted to
evaluate sine of 90 degrees
you can simply type in that search and
the result will be equal to 1 and
google's calculator will automatically
convert from radians to degrees
you can use natural language for other
things like 10 choose 3.
no need to fumble around with factorials
and division symbols you just get that
10 choose 3 is equal to 120. it's very
convenient to use natural language
you can also use google calculator to do
more complex calculations
for example i squared is equal to
negative 1.
we can do other complex calculations
like i to the power of i we get the
principal value of approximately 0.208
and it's really interesting that this is
a real number value for an imaginary
number raised to an imaginary number
i also like to use google's calculator
to resolve internet debates six divided
by two parentheses one plus two will
give you the correct answer of nine
you can also use google's calculator to
experiment
normally factorials we would think of
only inputting whole number values but
if you put in 0.5 exclamation point you
get the result of about 0.886
and this is exactly equal to the square
root of pi divided by 2 and if you're
curious about why i've made a separate
video on that topic
but google's calculator will solve many
problems and it'll also allow you to
experiment
the second trick is to use google to
graph functions you're not just limited
to this keypad you can also get
visualizations
here's the graph of sine of x you get a
two-dimensional plot and this is pretty
standard
but we're not just limited to
two-dimensional plots in google
we can type in a graph which has a
three-dimensional plot
here is the graph of sine of x plus
cosine of y
we get this beautiful plot that rotates
around
and we can actually understand the shape
of this surface
just from a google search
it's incredible
here's another incredible shape that we
can find
just in google search
you should experiment and you might even
find some heartwarming graphs
and that brings me to the next trick
which is a little more standard but you
can use google to convert units
here's one example you can convert 1
million in decimal into binary and
google naturally will give you the
result
but you can do more than just number
bases here's an example of converting
physical units
convert 75 fahrenheit to celsius and we
get that 75 fahrenheit is approximately
23.9
celsius and google even gives you the
formula for how this works
another example of converting units
which i use all the time in cooking
is let's say you wanted to convert 1
ounce into grams
you'll get the result of about 28.3
grams
so you can convert physical units but
you can also do more interesting things
like convert currency
type in convert 1usd to inr and you get
that one united states dollar is about
73.8 indian rupees you get a quote of
the spot price
the fourth thing you can do with google
is you can use it to split the bill
if you type in tip calculator you get
this nice little calculation
type in the bill amount the percentage
tip you want to give and the number of
people who are dining
you get the calculation of the tip per
person and the total that each person
needs to pay if you're splitting the
bill evenly
now there's no excuse for people
splitting the bill fairly
the fifth tip is to use google to get a
random number
sometimes you might just need to flip a
coin type in flip a coin and you'll get
a result of heads or tails if you need
more outcomes you can roll a dice and
google will give you one of the six
equally likely outcomes
but what if you need more than just six
outcomes or what if you need 5 or 10
you can also type in generate a random
number
you can type in a minimum and a maximum
value and google will generate a random
number between the minimum and maximum
and if all of this hasn't brought you
tremendous joy you can also use google
to get the answer to life the universe
and everything so these are a few of my
favorite math tricks what are yours
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on youtube
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world let's share the beauty
of mathematics with your help we can map
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle or
math topic presh mindyourdecisions.com
and if you so choose you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support